there are many kings in history who were
known as the great sir Ivan the forth of
Russia does not hold this epithet and is
commonly known as Ivan the Terrible this
raises the obvious question how terrible
was Ivan the Terrible terrible is the
translation of the Russian word Grozny
Grozny does mean terrible but not in the
modern sense with its moral undertones
so what did he do well Ivan the fourth
was actually the first Tsar of Russia
and his reign which was a long one was
one of tremendous reform which saw him
create many lasting Russian institutions
such as the Russian army which he
started from a Corps of professional
full-time soldiers called the strokes II
he also founded Russia's first
Parliament made up of the high-ranking
nobility could the zimsky suppor he
married a Romanov princess began the
Russian expansion into Siberia and
commissioned the very fancy st. Basil's
Cathedral sounds good right well yes but
Ivan was also responsible for certain
less good things Ivan's first wife died
in 1560 in some belief that this was his
breaking point after this Ivan's reign
was one of transformation and widespread
warfare this was followed by famine
discontent and potentially rebellion so
the Sodom was split into two halves the
zem shin at the southern core based
around the capital Moscow and the Opera
Janina the somewhat recently acquired
northern territories from the former
novgorod republic ivan never really
trusted those that lived in the
conquered territories and was somewhat
paranoid about their nobles called
boyars
one of the themes of Ivan's reign is his
paranoia surrounding the boyars and his
subsequent treatment of them he was
clever about his approach though in 1564
at the height of his popularity with the
people ivan abdicated the throne blaming
the boyars and their incessant scheming
the nobles were unhappy of this because
legally they couldn't govern without a
Tsar nobody wanted to pick a new one and
also they lived in a city full of people
who hated them they begged for him to
come back and he did so on one condition
he wanted to be an absolute monarch they
said yes which in hindsight was a
somewhat silly thing to do he returned
and not long afterwards founded the
approach Nicky this was a secret
prototype elyse force whose job it was
to do with traitors and also administer
the operation inna
plague and famine struck Russia in the
late 1560s neither was worried that the
people of novgorod might rebel there was
only one cause of action to win them
over and calm things down murder which
he did so by sacking the city also in
case you're wondering the approach Nicky
were disbanded in 1572 after it turned
out that they were only good at
repressing people but terrible at
fighting competent enemies much of
Ivan's efforts hereafter were dead
to neutering the nobility further and
centralizing his power there were limits
to how far he was willing to go to so in
1575 again he abdicated and it was
Simeon Ivan's close friend who took up
the position as Acting ruler Simeon then
totally of his own free will
decided to seize masses of land from the
church before Ivan returned in 1576
either condemned the seizure of these
valuable church lands as unchristian but
not enough to give them back obviously
by the way during this entire period
Russia was fighting a costly war called
the livonian war against all of these
countries this was because Ivan wanted
to incorporate Livonia into Russia
Russia lost something else have no
happened when Ivan was mistreating his
sons wife the two got into an argument
the question of loyalty came up and Ivan
son was like what are you gonna do beat
me to death with a scepter turns out yes
in the end Ivan's reputation as the
terrible beat in either the forceful or
evil senses comes almost entirely from
his treatment of the nobles his constant
warfare centralization of power and the
oppression icky alongside the murder of
his own son certainly soured his legacy
by borrowing the latter - there isn't
that much that's all too different from
Europe's at the rulers and none of those
are called the terrible I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patrons
that you see on screen now and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette ozark a
flash mark H party-boy Co David
archaeologist Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
onion Duck David Silverman Paul
Maggie packs Kowski Winston Hayward
vasily our vedas christian check hey
Anthony Beckett Skye Chappell Adam
Harvey and Ike